It's a question that has perplexed
humanity from as early as the anceint
greeks all the way to the twenty first
century, and we're still dying to know,
which came first?  The chicken, or the egg?
The question would be simple if we took
it literally.  Egg laying animals existed
far before chickens came about, so
technically the egg came before the chicken.
But this question, better worded as the
chicken or the chicken egg focuses
more on the cyclical cause and consequence.
That is if a chicken is born from an
egg, where did the egg come from? Another
chicken presumably, which too must have
come from an egg, so which came first?  On
the one side we have team chicken.  Research suggests that the protein
essential for the formation of chicken
eggs, called OV-17 is only
found in chicken ovaries.  Without it the
chicken eggshell could not be formed.
So without a chicken, you technically cannot get a chicken egg.
But this all depends on the nature and
definition of a chicken egg in the
first place.  Afterall, is a chicken egg an egg laid by a chicken? Or one that
simply contains a chicken?
Obviously the OV-17 bearing
chicken had to come from somewhere.
But if an elephant laid an egg from which a lion hatched, would it be an elephant egg or
a lion egg?  This leads to the other side
of the story, team egg.  During
reproduction two organisms pass along
their genetic information in the form of
DNA, but the replication of this
DNA is never one hundred percent
accurate and often produces minor
changes for the new organism.
These small mutations in DNA over
thousands of generations create new
species. But these genetic mutations must
occur in the zygote or initial cell, so
a creature very similar to a chicken (which
we could call a proto-chicken) would have
mated with another proto-chicken and
because of a small genetic mutation
created the first chicken,
which grew in an egg.  So the egg came
first?  Well team chicken might argue
that this was simply a chicken growing
inside of a proto-chicken egg.  However no-one
mutation can ever really constitute a
new species.  Even though we humans like
classify all creatures into
different groups and names
this is based on how things currently
are, and not how they were millions of
years ago.
The process of evolution is so gradual
that no one proto-chick to chicken birth
could really be considered a new species
at the time.  Much like how dogs have
come from wolves, as humans began to
interact with and domesticate wolves
there was no one single point where a wolf gave birth to a dog.
But rather as particular traits came
about from selective pressures such as,
choosing wolves who were not afraid of
humans, or ones that were less aggressive
over many generations we conceived big
genetic and behavioral trait differences.
So where does this leave us?  We are left
with two scenarios.  Some early egg laying
species gradually lead to the creation
of the proto-chicken which laid proto-chicken
eggs.  In one of these eggs there
was a mutation causing a slight change
and selective advantage and this was
ultimately the first chicken which then
went on to lay chicken eggs.
In this case the chicken technically
came first.  Or we have a
proto-chicken which gave birth to a
chicken inside of what we would classify
as a chicken egg and as such the
egg came first.  Which brings us back to
the nomenclature and question of, what is
a chicken egg?  Which is a fairly
meaningless question, but at the end of
the day, what we can all agree on is that
regardless of whether it was a chicken
egg or a proto-chicken egg, the first true
chicken came from an egg. The egg
came first.
Got a burning question one answered?  Ask
in the comments, or on facebook and twitter
and subscribe for more weekly science
videos.